und jetzt ist die große neue
spd-mannschaft in den Bundestag
eingezogen und es gibt sozusagen ein
Klassenfoto kann man sagen alle zusammen
jetzt erstmal Schultag hier hier sehen
wir alles mit diesem allerersten
Mannschaft so der Klassenfoto wie
Patricia sagt Bild politik-chef Jan
Schäfer bei uns im Studio gibt es
richtig
Ärger warum ja es gibt zu Recht Ärger
guten Morgen erst einmal denn dieses
Foto oder die Bilder die wir gesehen
haben die sind ja absolute Gipfel der
Masken Heuchelei wir erinnern uns die
SPD beteiligt an allen Entscheidungen
zum Thema maskenpflicht auch wir haben
in Schulen in vielen vielen Schulklassen
immer noch die maskenpflicht das heißt
die Schülerinnen und Schüler tragen
sogar im Unterricht obwohl sie mit
Abstand sitzen eine Maske und hier
stellt man sich jetzt auf um zu
applaudieren sich selbst zu feiern und
natürlich ohne Maske das immer an
Doppelmoral nicht zu überbieten wir sind
denn da überhaupt die Regelungen sonst
also geht überall in Deutschland in
Schulen maskenpflicht aber im Bundestag
nicht oder Bundestag gilt auch die
maskenpflicht die ist sogar erst noch
verlängert worden von Wolfgang
Bundestagspräsident absolut deswegen ist
ja die Kritik daran auch absolut
berechtigt sie geht bis zum 31 Oktober
und wir sehen ja auch auf den Bildern
dass viele der Abgeordneten ihre Maske
noch in der Hand halten oder sogar um
den Arm gebunden haben fünf Abgeordnete
haben wir gezählt unter anderem Karl
Lauterbach tragen auch noch eine Maske
also das heißt man ist zusammengekommen
offenbar mit Maske wie sich das auch im
Bundestag dann gehört wie es zumindest
als Regel vorgeschrieben ist dann hat
man wohl gesagt Mensch das sieht so doof
aus ihr mit Maske nimmt sie doch stellt
euch mal ganz ganz eng zusammen und
nimmt sie ab und dann sind offenbar alle
Hüllen und alle Vorbehalte gefallen hat
mir gesagt nee stimmt wir haben doch die
Wahl gewonnen jetzt gratulieren wir uns
mal richtig fangen an zu applaudieren
und das ganze ohne Maske auch müssen wir
noch mal daran erinnern dass er die SPD
die pandemische Lage erst vor kurzem
noch mit verlängert hat also da ist ganz
ganz viel Corona Angst Corona Panik mit
dabei aber wenn es ums Feiern geht dann
lässt man im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
die Maske fallen ein Foto geht also das
dritte ist ja auch noch mal anschauen
auch die Menschen die man darauf sieht
ne dass wir darauf nochmal spazieren
gehen und wir sind in der Mitte
natürlich Olaf Scholz genau die Sitzung
von dieser neuen riesigen SPD-Fraktion
die fand ja im Plenarsaal statt aus
corona-gründen weil man da eben schön
weit auseinander sitzen kann ne da gehen
die da aus dem Plenarsaal raus und
stehen sich schön dicht aneinander fürs
Foto damit saugt wirklich ganz familiär
aussieht und genau auf ein Foto bringen
auf die Nase einmal noch mal
normalerweise Tagen die Fraktionen in
ihren fraktionsszenen da sitzt man eng
an eng getränkt jetzt ist die Fraktion
der SPD deutlich stärker seit der
Bundestagswahl 206 Abgeordnete und wie
du es gerade richtig gesagt hast gesagt
hast Kai kommt man jetzt zusammen oder
ist man zusammengekommen in dem
bundestagssitzungssaal dem großen
Plenarsaal da passen zur Zeit 709
Abgeordnete rein deswegen die 206 hatten
reichlich Platz und heißt extra gewählt
damit die Abgeordneten Platz haben aber
danach du hast einfach so schön man
wollte noch mal zeigen wenn ich wie
stark wir sind und stellt sich dann ganz
eng gedrängt aneinander fängt sogar noch
an vor lauter Lust zu klatschen
berauscht sich am eigenen Erfolg und ich
frage mich auch was sollen eigentlich
beispielsweise die Wirte denken die
abkassiert wurden die Bußgelder bezahlen
mussten weil sie vielleicht den ein oder
anderen Gast ohne Maske bewirtet hatten
oder überhaupt geöffnet hatten wir
erinnern uns an jagdzenen in Parks weil
Menschen sich nicht an corona-maßnahmen
gehalten hatten und hier im Bundestag
stellt sich die stärkste Fraktion und
sagt ist uns alles Wurst und vor allen
Dingen an Klassenzimmer eben also hier
in Berlin wird zumindest dafür
Grundschüler jetzt die maskenpflicht
fallen wie in einzelnen Bundesländern in
Sachsen zum Beispiel aber immer noch
Millionen Schüler und Schülerinnen
müssen jeden Tag die ganze Zeit die
ganze Schulzeit bis zum Mittag oder
Nachmittag ihre Maske auf behalten und
da stellt man sich dann lässig in den
Bundestag und nimmt die Maske also ist
wie gesagt anscheinend Helligkeit und
Doppelmoral nicht zu überbieten
interessant auch die Frage konnte sich
Karl Lauterbach nicht durchsetzen
möglicherweise hat er gerufen lass die
Masken auf man weiß es nicht genau da
müssen wir noch mal nachgehen dem Ganzen
aber ganz klar ist er hat dort keine
Mehrheit gehabt der Siegesrausch der
Jubel und das Triumph Gefühl das hat
selbst die Maske
nicht durchsetzen gegen Karl Lauterbach
auch das erzählt die Geschichte ja alle
wollten sie wegnehmen und Karl
Lauterbach sagt nee Freunde also
maskenpflicht da bin ich immer noch
unbedingt und dieses Foto bei uns im
Studio Bild meinungschef Philipp
piathoff sorgt jetzt für Aufregung auch
dich regt es auf warum ja man muss sich
das Foto mal ganz genau anschauen und
schauen was da eventuell fehlt was
könnte es denn sein wenn man sich dieses
Foto mal anschaut also meine Tochter
wüsste sofort ja ehrlich gesagt ich sehe
ganz viele Jacken und Hosen und
Krawatten und Hemden aber die Maske
fehlt und ehrlich gesagt mich persönlich
stört es überhaupt nicht dass diese
Menschen ohne Maske dastehen mein
Problem ist das Politiker und seit
anderthalb Jahren erzählen und vor allem
Eltern erzählen dass sie ohne Maske
wirklich lebensgefährlich erkranken
dürfen
und wirklich bei aller Kritik an Karl
Lauterbach die ich habe der ist
zumindest konsequent sieht's durch dann
dieses Foto ist das Foto der Doppelmoral
man sieht hier Politiker die seit
anderthalb Jahren uns dazu zwingen Maske
zu tragen gerade in solchen Situationen
wenn man nah beieinander ist im
Innenraum also da wo es wirklich
lebensgefährlich ist wenn man mal mit
die Maske absetzt ja und hier stehen sie
da obwohl massenpflicht im Bundestag
gilt und tragen keine Maske ich sehe
ehrlich gesagt nur eine Chance für die
da wieder rauszukommen und zwar wenn Sie
das erste was Sie im Bundestag machen
ist die maskenpflicht abzuschaffen dann
kann man sagen ihr habt es verstanden
ihr wollt dass wir die gleichen Regeln
haben die ihr habt ansonsten ist es halt
Doppelmoral aber das Gegenteil passiert
die haben sie gerade noch verlängert bis
Ende Oktober also und dann stellen sie
sich zusammen für dieses Foto
was gibt es auch für ein Signal Philipp
nach außen von all die Menschen auch an
die Schüler gutes in Berlin am Montag
dürfen wenigstens die Grundschüler schon
mal die Maske ausziehen aber dennoch es
gibt noch genug Schüler in Deutschland
die stundenlang mit Maske im
Klassenzimmer sitzen und jetzt sehen wir
Politiker fotografieren sich ohne
Abstand ohne Maske eine Ausnahme also
ein paar vereinzeln auch in den hinteren
Reihen aber ganz vorne prominent sehen
wir Karl Lauterbach welches Signal wird
da gesendet Schüler müssen die Maske
tragen aber auch ganz normale Menschen
die doppelt geimpft sind die doch
dreimal geimpft sind müssen die Maske
weiterhin in den Innenräumen tragen ein
ganz ganz vielen Orten und ehrlich
gesagt ich bin froh dass es dieses Foto
gibt weil hier passiert endlich mal das
vor der Kamera was wir alle die mit
Politikern regelmäßig seit anderthalb
Jahren zu tun haben wissen ja Politiker
halten sich auch nicht an alle Regeln
und die nehmen auch die Maske bei der
erstbesten Gelegenheit ab klar fürs Foto
da stellt sich Markus Söder natürlich
hin mit seiner ffp2 ffp3-maske aber
selbst wenn er alleine auf dem Berg
steht aber Politik und ich spreche jetzt
nicht von Markus Söder mit dem weich
privat noch nie unterwegs aber ganz
viele polit Streifen die Maske sofort
bei der besten Gelegenheit ab das ist
dieses klassische Phänomen werden
Politiker eine Kamera sieht und sofort
die Zigarette wegschmeißt bloß nichts
vor der Kunde einer hat ja neulich
gesagt Wolfgang Kubicki bei Paul
ronsheimer Interview der hat das
zugegeben dass er sich nicht immer an
die corona-regeln gehalten hat hat
dadurch ordentlich was eingesteckt
anschließend an Kritik auch aus den rein
auch von den 206 Abgeordneten dort von
der SPD und jetzt zeigen die eben auf
dem Foto ja es ist halt Realität Leute
es ist Realität in Deutschland ja es
gibt diese strengen Regeln und die die
unsinnig sind die befolgt man einfach
auch nicht immer offenbar in rein der
SPD-Fraktion aber warum kann
[Musik]